foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Reynolds you knew that right Harold
I knew it was uh around that I was
guessing 231 while you're going through
that that was kind of my number but all
right Harold Reynolds uh MLB network
analyst the postseason begins tomorrow
and you can watch Harold on MLB
Network's coverage throughout they'll
air live before and after every game the
schedule in its entirety available at
mlb.com all right we got a poll question
I'll give you Albert Pujol's career
or your good buddy Ken Griffey Jr
wow that was a tough one um but it
really wasn't that difficult I'd say
Griffey oh you know I look at Albert's
numbers yes incredible but griffy's
career just uh all the things that came
with it the 19 years old when he broke
in everybody knew who he was uh he
dominated he changed the sport
all those things I think are probably
maybe bigger than the numbers well I
don't think Albert gets the respect that
he probably should but riffy did well we
likened Albert Pujols to Tim Duncan we
like Junior to Allen Iverson
I can see that yeah
the the the the the flare and what he
captured yeah that's what like Iverson
did right yeah the lightning in a bottle
yeah
yeah uh how big a favorites are the
Dodgers and how big a favorite should
they be
well I think they're probably highly
favored but I don't think I think
they're overrated with the favoritism
I'm a little concerned about their
starting pitching
uh the top three guys in the lineup I
think have a chance to be all Hall of
Fame potential players mookie Freddie
Freeman Trey Turner credible
but there's a drop off after that and I
and I think the pitching uh is not where
it was at you lose Walker Bueller that
was a huge blow to them and scherzer's
now with the Mets so you look at the
staff from last year that didn't get all
the way there they're two down I just
don't see it
all right so then Dodgers still the
favorites
right
yeah I I still think the Braves are the
favorite oh okay all right well
defending champs here so you got the
Braves as the team to beat yeah all
right uh second best team in bet let's
look at the best teams in baseball so
American League and nationally you got
the Braves is the best team in baseball
the Braves are the best team in baseball
I think the Mets have the best outside
chance of lightning and being able if
you've got shares underground to win two
games a series
you got a chance to to win it all and
they have the potential to do that they
haven't pitched a full season they've
got another 100 innings in them and I
think the injuries early on puts them
out of real strength heading into the
postseason are we past our hatred or
should we be past our hatred for the
Astros
we should be past it because a lot of
those players no longer are there
but
um they are overlooked it's a very
talented team I think they're the best
probably in the American League although
my sleeper is the Blue Jays oh people
are overlooking the Jays got a lot of
young Talent there young Talent
um they got an ace in Manila
um burials can be there I think they got
the staff that can do it the bullpen's
there
and then the outside probably the best
pitching might be the Mariners they're
probably the best pitching I don't think
your Mariners your Mariners my Mariners
I think the lineup is strong enough no
uh is uh Altuve going to be a first
battle of Hall of Famer
he should be but he might get the Robbie
Alamar treatment where a lot of guys
held Robbie back for a year because he
spit on the Umpire and had that
controversy with the the the uh what's
the garbage can get I guess we might
call it yeah they might punish Altuve
for that but he's he's a a tremendous
talent I think he's a first ballot Hall
of Famer
yeah I I wondered about that of how long
do you punish somebody for something
like that
and the crazy thing about Altuve and
it's been backed up by so many people he
never wanted signs he he didn't want
people to tell him what was coming or
nothing and I've played with guys like
that you know Alvin Davis never wanted
to pitch Tony Gwynn never wanted to know
you know I wanted to know
let me know so you didn't know you had
guys who would signal if they were on
second base they would let you know I I
used to do that quite a bit you know Ken
Phelps was like I'll take two strikes
for you to get the second steal the base
and let me know and uh yeah I had one
time Johnny Moses gave me the wrong sign
I thought it was going to be a breaking
ball and it was a fastball almost hit me
and after that I was like I don't want
any more okay how would you signal me if
I'm at the plate and it's going to be a
breaking ball well there's a couple
different ways one uh I would go to my
knees like if I stand up right now yeah
all right so if I go down like this you
can't really see my my fullness of my
knees but I may have my hands open like
this breaking ball I went like this
breaking ball you know or I might walk
off if the base is over here I would
look to the base and that would let you
know it's going to be outside or look
this way it might be inside depending on
the picture so and a lot of times I got
the sign from pictures when they're in
their glove trying to see what grip it
might be oh that's a change up grip oh
that was a slider grip you know stuff
like that what was it like when a
pitcher is tipping his pitches and
everybody in the lineup knows
it was great I mean it was joyful Jack
Morris Hall of Fame pitcher right he had
a year I think he lost I think 18 games
in 20 games or something like that in
Detroit and this is after he was killing
the league well we would go to places
and Robbie Alamar be in Toronto or Joe
Carter said have you guys faced Jack
Morris yet when he comes up to his chest
it's a split if he goes below his legs
it's a fastball and it's like oh
beautiful thank you wait so the whole
league is telling each other they're
passing it on you know that hey this is
how you get this guy
um the the Blue Jays back in the day
would Molitor Joe Carter those guys were
the best and the the uh Brewers were
really good too Robin you out and those
guys they really knew how to tip pitches
and be able to pick up tendencies
who does it now who tips pitches thank
you have have you heard of somebody
tipping their pitches this year oh yeah
yeah those pictures are always going to
tip they're always going to tip pitches
and today
the the with technology if I could have
had technology down and got on an iPad
and been able to go oh man here's what
he does it's a game changer and so I
think we're still gonna eventually I
think they're gonna have to get to a
point where you can't have iPads on the
bench it's just too easy okay but at
what point is this cheating what is it
where is it I mean okay the cheating to
me is what the Astros did they took it
to another level they took technology
and made it like you took away the the
thinking of being able to create it with
your own mindset you had a computer
telling you what was going on and then
you're banging on the garbage can so let
a guy know your intellectual thought was
out of it if I can intellectually say
hey Dan's gonna lift his right arm every
time he gets ready to to step off then
okay that's great but if I got a
computer down to a science now that's
not that's not fair
uh Aaron judge the season has been
labeled the greatest season of all time
when you factor in relief pitchers you
factor in the ball is not lively there's
testing I mean we go down the list of
all the things all the categories he led
uh baseball in this year
in your mind the best season ever turned
in by a hitter is who
who well I mean Aaron all the factors
you threw in I gotta look at and say
yeah it was it was incredible but if you
go back and look at the year Babe Ruth
hit 60 homers he had like a 160 some
RBIs I think he hit 340 350. I mean
that's ridiculous so I I think the one
thing with 62 home runs and he had 130
RBIs I'd like to see him have more you
know um but that's when we play the game
you got him leading off and hitting
second yeah so but what he did this year
with all the things factored in I think
the number one thing is the testing
because that was the most controversial
thing in the past that's why I don't
think a lot of people really truly
followed this amazing year that he had
because of it was you know we got a guy
sitting out there with 73 or 74 homers
and two other guys that were over 62. so
that changes the hunt so to speak
and I feel bad for the baseball fan and
a lot of those fans are over 50 years of
age they've been covering you know
following the sport for such a long
period of time and and you're not quite
sure what to believe and when we were
growing up I would never have thought
that somehow some way that that guy is
not who I think he is
now you know hey do you like bonds uh
all right he's the old-time home run
champer single season champ or you don't
like him now you got Aaron judge it it
shouldn't work that way in sports
and baseball has done this to itself
and I don't know how we get out of this
unless
you know 10 years from now
20 years from now I mean it feels like
it's just it's it still lingers Harold
well I don't even know if it's just
baseball's done it to itself I think our
culture you know whether it's track a
guy runs a a nine flat hundred now I'm
just throwing a number out there we go
as authentic you know we don't know
because of all the guys that have come
in the past it's more the time that
we're in and it's it's it's happening in
sports I see guys uh make unbelievable
plays or look like a physical specimen
the first thing your mind goes to is
yeah how do you get there and I think
it's just the times that we're in not
just baseball well remember when the
guys wanted to show you their new
physique
yes and then all of a sudden like Nomar
wanted to show you his physique and then
all of a sudden Manny wanted to look
like a sack of laundry there when he
went to the play
oh yeah no doubt about it uh it's it's
definitely changed everything
you're funny you didn't you didn't use
though
no I never did I never did
um I was actually no Harold I was
kidding obviously you didn't use I mean
I saw your numbers and and I see how
you're built like you obviously didn't
use
like uh we're starting to become aware
of it towards the end of my career and I
remember talking to our trainer Rick
Griffin and I said man I got to get on
that program some of these guys in
Oakland are on I want to start
no you don't so he started really
starting to understand it and explain it
to guys what was going on yeah but it
forced guys almost by proxy that they're
doing it do I need to do it and and am I
going to be the guy who's not doing it
so that peer pressure probably provoked
a lot of guys prompted guys to go all
right I guess everybody else is doing it
why don't I well that and do you want to
have an opportunity to continue to play
so that's why you had to throw in all
the restrictions and really get to the
bottom of it to make it a fair playing
field yeah and you know one thing we
always forget it's not healthy you know
we act like oh they just took some some
m m candies and they'll get over it no
this is affecting people's bodies and
they may not live long because of it did
you take amphetamines did you try
amphetamines no I never did anything Dan
I've never even smoked never weed none
of that stuff I just didn't grow up with
it so a little different for me yeah
because that's where people with the
steroid error go yeah what about the
guys who were taking Greenies and I'm
going the Greenies don't hit the ball
400 feet yeah they they just help you
maybe stay awake you know after that
that uh double header the night before
and then you got to play a day game
something like that yeah I I grew up in
the uh an interesting time I mean I
remember running in spring training and
it smelled like a brewery with guys
blowing stuff back at me that was that
was like what guys did you know guys
smoking cigarettes in The Dugout I
remember first time I saw Al Cowans I'm
going to the plate and he's sitting down
smoking a cigarette I'm like what
during a game during the game and just
sitting on the steps you know that was
part of it well there's that famous
Sports Illustrated cover with Dick Allen
on the cover with the White Sox and he's
juggling The Baseballs and he's got a
heater in his mouth yeah and he's
thinking that's cool right because that
was the culture yeah well that was no
big deal Dick Allen was cool he was yes
he was he was a bad man all right Your
World Series pick is oh
um I'm going Atlanta
and
I know I said Toronto's my outside pick
I still got to go Atlanta and Houston
you got to beat Houston for me okay now
I think the defending chaps are the best
team right now great to talk to you
buddy our best uh all the guys on the
set there thanks for joining us thanks
uh Harold Reynolds MLB network analyst
uh worked with Harold for a long time at
the mothership MLB Network their
coverage throughout airs live before and
after every game the schedule in its
entirety available at mlb.com